Okay.
Well, I think we'll make a start. We've
got plenty plenty of material to go
through and um
I'm sure you want to get through as much
of it as you possibly can.
Just I'll just say a a quick sort of
hello, introduce the session, and then
I'm going to be handing over to Tom
who's running running the running the
workshop. So, my name is Peter Crocker,
one of the co-founders of
the company Oxford Semantics
Oxford Semantics Technologies and um
yeah, pleasure to to have you this
afternoon to come and have a look at
what is um
what is reasoning, get experience with
our product AudioFox,
and hopefully come away with
with some experience of of how you could
how you could use this
with a very hands-on session.
Tom's going to be running running us
through. If you can't follow along on
your own machine,
you're still going to get plenty out of
this cuz Tom will be showing you I think
everything everything you would
otherwise be be doing. So, plenty of
opportunity to to get stuck in.
We've got a decent number here, but I I
think there's plenty of opportunity for
questions. So, if you do get stuck at
any point, we're going to be a few of us
sort of lurking around. Chenzi, put your
hand up. That'll be great. So, Chenzi's
one of the one of the team as well, and
yeah, I think with that, Tom, over to
you.
>> Cool. Thank you.
Um yeah.
Welcome everyone
to the ultimate guide to semantic
reasoning.
Um
we're going to be covering a few things
today. The focus is is going to be like
almost entirely
reasoning based,
but then we're going to touch a little
bit at the end on how this kind of
relates to
rag, which is sort of
one of the buzzwords at the minute, one
of the hot topics, and has been spoken
about loads throughout the conference
already, and we're like halfway through
day one. So,
um
yeah, as Peter said, um
questions are
not just welcome, but really, really
encouraged. Um
the point of uh this workshop at least
is sort of to teach you and to to bring
you up to speed with what we uh or what
reasoning has to offer. And so, if I'm
going through something too quickly, or
if I've not like explained something
well enough, or anything, um or even you
you just want to go down a diversion
that I'm not immediately going down, um
this is an opportunity for us to have
that conversation. So, just like raise
your hand or shout out or interrupt me
or whatever, um and we can we can go
from there.
Uh
there are a couple people still
filtering in, so if you do want to
follow along, scan the QR code on your
desk, um and you can like download the
the exercises and the data and and all
that stuff.
So um
can I just get a show of hands, who is
following along? Like
1 2 3
sort of Okay, cool. That's fine.
Um there might be a couple of like setup
um steps. So, those of you well, not
might be there are a couple of setup
steps. So, for those of you who aren't
following along, um we have a demo that
you can play with, but those of you uh
who are,
um if you get stuck at any point, and I
expect that
you will, cuz in a room this big,
there's always a few.
Um we have uh yeah, Chenzi and Peter and
myself like dart around, so we can help.
So, again, please just raise your hand
uh as early as you can, and we can get
it get it sorted quickly.
Um
but as I said, all of this is about
reasoning.
Um
so,
I want to share with you some motivation
as to why we're even giving this
session. Um what can reasoning do for
you? Well,
on the left here, uh we have a query
uh that's just written without any
reasoning, without any rules in the
system, um and pretty pretty long,
um, pretty sort of complicated. I
certainly couldn't see what this like
does at a glance. Um, but on the right
I'm going to edit it out a few times.
Um,
on the right is functionally the same
query, so it gives you the same results,
but it's much shorter, um, and this is
after we've added some rules. So, um,
straight away you can see that it's
going to be quicker to write,
uh, easier to share, easier to debug,
that sort of thing.
Uh, but also if you'll see in the bottom
right-hand corner here,
uh, this is the time that this query
takes to execute. And the one on the
right is about four times, uh, faster.
So,
even with what is a relatively simple
query in a real practical setting,
um, you're getting a speed up of 4x. So,
imagine this scaled to a production
system where you can really get, uh,
like vastly quicker queries,
uh out.
This is not all that reasoning can do.
There's a lot that goes beyond queries,
um, but this is a fantastic entry point
and it's a great sort of motivator for
people to get going with it.
Um, we've had a few people come in.
That's awesome.
Um,
there's a a QR code on your desk if you
do want to follow along and like do
exercises and that sort of thing. So,
scan that. We'll send you a package. Uh,
yeah, download and kind of go as we go
if that's all right. Um, but yeah, we'll
we'll get you going.
Everything that we're going to cover
today revolves around the sport Formula
1 and one of our old demos, which lets
you ask the question, who is the
greatest Formula 1 driver of all time?
Uh, and that's actually a bit of a
subjective question because there's
loads that goes into, um,
a good driver.
They have different cars, so just
because you're winning a race doesn't
mean you're a good driver. It might just
mean you've got a fast car.
Um, so our demo here lets you sort of
play around with all of those pieces um,
and sort of figure out what you think
would be
uh, would determine the best driver
uh, in your sort of situation. So it it
emulates a business scenario where
there's lots of parameters and it gives
you the control to uh, make your own
decisions.
It's live at f1.adyfox.tech. So
particularly during the setup stage, if
anybody's sort of got a minute for of
like down time or anything like that
whilst we set up, check it out. It's
pretty cool. Um, and the reason that
we're showing you this is because all of
the queries, all of the rules, all of
the axioms that we're going to write
uh, are all part of this demo. So they
real they really are being used by us
for a sort of real system. It's not just
a like academic exercise. The hope is
that this stuff, while it's not by any
means a comprehensive overview,
uh, it is going to be enough to give you
the foundations to kind of go away and
build something real
or at least start asking uh, the right
questions or looking in the right places
um, for your production systems.
Uh, as I keep saying,
this is like a follow along workshop. So
if you do want to follow along, scan the
QR code. Uh, there are instructions
within. I'm going to go through them
now. Um, I might leave some people
behind, but we do have some people in
the room, Chenzi and Peter, who are
going to like help out if anybody does
get stuck. Um, please raise your hands
as early as you can because
we've never done a workshop where like
everyone's got through smoothly. So it's
much easier for us if you kind of get in
early, we help out, and we go from
there.
Um, but yeah.
That's that's fine. The second thing,
uh, I'm going to be going through all of
this in VS Code. Uh, you are going to
need some kind of
uh, like text editor or ideally an IDE.
Um,
obviously other IDEs are available. Um
use them at your own peril.
I'm I'm not going to go through the
setup for all of them because there's
like a thousand. So, if you're really
confident please use what you want. But,
if you're not, please use VS Code. Uh
and if you do, if you run into any
problems, we will come around and fix it
for you.
Okay. So,
that's the the sort of intro done. What
are our objectives?
First is to cover the real basics of
what is reasoning. Then we're going to
get you set up with RDFox. This
hopefully will give you a minute to uh
down that download that package if
you're if you're wanting to do that. Um
and then we're going to run through some
queries.
Then we're going to actually move on to
the reasoning itself. So, all of that
just allows you to uh kind of access
this reasoning part uh where we're going
to run through a handful of OWL axioms
and then a bunch of Datalog rules.
So,
um
many of you will be familiar with OWL.
It's the sort of um well, it is the
standard. Um
less of you will be familiar with
Datalog, but it's a much more expressive
language that allows you to do things
that go beyond uh queries like I've I've
mentioned before. So, that's where we
can do things like aggregates, negation,
filters.
Um we can even do stuff like recursion
that goes way beyond what is even
remotely possible with queries.
Um and uh yeah, it's it's a much nicer
language to work with. So, the the focus
really is going to be on that towards uh
the end at least.
All right, I'm going to stop there. Does
anybody have any questions at this
point? Um about anything at all?
Because
yeah.
We love questions here.
Okay cool.
Um
So,
I've just realized I might have some
people online
uh who need a link to the download page.
Right.
Uh apologies folks online.
Um
if you want to follow along,
you can do so here.
Uh good okey. So,
what is semantic reasoning? Well,
um it's been mentioned quite a lot, as
I've said,
uh but often in sort of vague terms, but
really what it does is it helps you
enrich your data store. It takes the
context of your data and expert
knowledge that is encoded into rules,
um and it adds to your data store. So,
you end up adding new triples to what
you have already.
Um
this really allows you to ask and answer
more complex questions, and that's
really where uh it empowers rag because
it takes you beyond the sort of triple
um the traditional rag approach that
just allows you to ans- or ask very
simple basic questions,
um and empowers you to do much much
more.
As we've already said, it drastically
improves performance and also allows you
to do things that go beyond the
functionality of queries alone.
Um that second piece we're not really
going to talk about today. So, if
anybody does want to chat about uh how
you can use this to go beyond queries,
uh either catch us at the booth or stick
around afterwards and we can have a
chat. Um but the the main thing we're
going to look at is uh performance
enhancements uh during during this uh
session.
There's a final piece though
that is incremental reasoning,
um which means all of this all of the um
addition of triples addition of data uh
happens automatically and
uh in real time as you add new data that
is impacted by these rules. So, um again
we'll kind of demonstrate that later and
it might not mean much right now, but
later when it becomes super easy,
hopefully you'll see see the power in
that.
um
And again to add a bit more context, the
kind of or an example of a rule would be
uh what you can see on the left here.
Um we have our raw data about our
company OST and our five founders.
And a rule that we've written is count
the number of founders. So, all Onto Fox
will do is literally count the number of
founders and add the triple OST has
number of founders five. So, now instead
of doing that count every time we query,
we can directly access this piece of
information um which obviously is much
much faster than doing the count.
Uh and I've mentioned it a few times,
but we're going to be working with Onto
Fox, which is a knowledge graph and
reasoning engine. Hopefully, most of you
guys know what a knowledge graph is uh
and by the end of this you should know
what a reasoning engine is, too.
We have this uh incremental reasoning
piece which uh is is pretty special uh
and again we'll we'll get to that
uh slightly later.
Um it's incredibly fast and scalable.
So, uh we go from everything on device
on edge device, which we have um
an instance running on a a Raspberry Pi
or or an Arduino or something on our uh
booth. So, if you're interested in that,
come check it out. Uh but we also go all
the way up to like huge AWS instances
and can uh import Wiki data in like a
couple of hours or something like that.
So um
yeah, huge scalability and all All this
comes from our Oxford pedigree. So,
uh lots and lots of work was done for
the past
uh several decades by uh three of our
professors who ended up spinning out the
company with uh
Peter and our our other founder, Adam.
Okay so
now I'm going to get on to the setup of
AdiFox for those who are going to follow
along. For those who aren't following
along, now would be a good time to check
out the demo.
Um but does anybody have any questions?
Cool.
Right, so step one, download the
package. Hopefully
everyone's done that.
If not, it is not too late. You you
still have time, but um I'm going to
obviously move on.
Um
is anybody having any trouble with that,
by the way? Um
It it might have taken a a minute. We
have to go through them like manually.
No? All good?
Cool. So, once you've got the package
downloaded it, uh I'm going to want you
to open it in VS Code. So,
uh
pretty simple. Just go to VS Code,
hit file, and open folder, and you want
to find
the folder that we've just uh given you
that you've downloaded.
Um the kind of really important parts
are that you have uh one layer of CDL 24
at the top here.
Uh
one at the top there.
Um particularly if you're on Windows,
something that happens all the time is
when you unzip a folder, it puts it in a
folder of its own name.
I don't know why. It's it's Windows.
Um
but
if you open the sort of outer one, um
that will like mess mess the commands
up. So, uh we'll we'll run into some
some problems there. So,
uh make sure you're doing that. If you
do see two layers,
just do the same thing again. File, open
folder, and that that in a folder.
Uh once you've done that, you're going
to want to open a terminal, which again,
pretty simple. Just go to terminal, new
terminal.
And then,
depending on
what file system you're using,
you're going to want to run one of these
four commands.
Um I'm on
what Mac arm, so I'm going to use the
top one.
You may not be on Mac arm, don't use the
Um
but if you're copy-pasting this, be
careful that it doesn't introduce
spaces, that it doesn't get rid of like
any of the slashes or the underscores or
something like that. Um
again, I'm not sure why that happens
often on Windows, but just just be a bit
careful when you do.
Um
but by doing that,
we are going to start our Defox, and
then we're kind of good to go.
So,
I've got this message here that the REST
endpoint was successfully started. Um
and that's a pretty good telltale sign
that I've done the right thing. So, if
if you're seeing that message, you've
probably done the right thing. If if
you're not,
yeah.
>> Is Arbutus free to use for a certain
time on your on your own laptop, etc.?
>> Yes. So,
>> How long?
>> You can get a 30-day free trial. Uh
actually, by like participating here,
you've already got a 30-day free free
trial.
So,
yeah, you're welcome.
Um but after that, I think you can get
up to two more free trials, and then we
need to go into some
additional thing. We normally give or
not normally, we can give up to three
free trials um because of our our
licensing with the university.
Um but yeah, then it's a then it's paid
model.
>> Can you show the
command again?
>> Uh, yep.
Uh, I should say as well, this deck is
in the folder that I gave you or or that
you downloaded. So,
um, for all of these instructions, they
are
in the in the slides from slide 10, I
think. Uh, and these are on slide 12.
Uh, if any of these if if you're running
this and you're getting problems, there
are common fixes
on slide 14. Check those out. Uh, but
also,
please do raise your hand if you're
encountering any issues cuz
yeah, we we always encounter issues.
Yeah?
>> Can you go back to the command?
>> Of course.
It is.
>> Great, thank you.
>> So, yeah, if you want to copy and paste
this, it's it's in the deck which is in
that folder. So,
uh,
uh, and you should see on again on slide
13, you should see the sort of output
which,
uh,
if you're doing it all right, should say
something like the rest endpoint was
successfully started.
Um, if it says something else,
that's a problem.
>> And it runs in the background?
>> Yep.
Yep.
Anybody Anybody running into issues
here?
>> There's somebody online
>> Oh, yeah?
Uh,
cool.
Uh, it sounds like Peter's got you
sorted, Andrew. So, hopefully you should
see hear from him soon.
Um,
all right. I really don't believe that
there are no problems. All right, this
has never happened.
So.
>> Yeah, I got um
>> Yeah?
>> Could not be loaded.
>> Awesome. Chenzi, could you
help out?
Thank you.
But it's never just one either. There's
There's no way. I don't I don't believe
it. Is anybody else sitting there just
like
confused and like not really sure what's
what's happening?
No?
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
All right. On your head be it.
Um
So, let's have a look at what we've just
done. Uh we've just started RDFox in
sandbox mode,
uh which is a sort of playground.
We've used the start script,
um which has done a few things. First,
it's created a data store. We've called
it F1.
You can obviously in your own time call
it whatever you want. We've activated it
so that we can work with it in the
terminal. We've imported some prefixes,
set the output to out, and started the
endpoint so we can access it um via our
UI, or if you wanted to use any uh like
APIs, you'd have to have to go through
this first.
Uh but again, this is important to know
should you wish to use this in your own
time because you will have to run these
commands or uh something similar.
Okay. So,
once you've done that,
we're going to open the UI and move away
from um
the terminal for a while.
We're going to have to go to localhost
12110  console.
And you should be welcomed with a screen
like this.
And simply select the data store F1.
Sorry?
>> My port again?
>> Uh 12110.
Uh this guy here.
>> So, is that big enough for everyone?
Mhm.
Bit small at the back?
I don't know if that's going to do much
for my
bar, but that might
help a little bit.
Okay-dokey. So,
we've opened up the console, we've
selected the data store F1. Now it's
time to import some data.
Uh and again, this is in the folder that
we gave you before.
There's a a folder within that folder
called data and a file within that
folder called up to 2020. You're going
to want to
first click
um add content in the top right-hand
corner of the console.
Then just drag and drop
the
data up to 2020,
which is here,
into this window. Uh again, there are a
few files here. The only one we want is
up to 2020. Um the reason for that will
become clear as we do this like big
reveal right at the end. Um but for now,
just up to 2020.
Uh you'll see a little sort of preview
there and just click add content.
And in about a second, it's going to add
4.5 million facts.
So, fairly fairly speedy.
Um we just click okay and we're we're
good to go.
So,
>> Does this support importing trig?
>> Uh yeah.
Yep.
Um
yeah.
Um cool. Is anybody
anybody not been able to do this?
Cuz
I am going through this quite quickly. I
would normally spend a lot more time on
this, but we're quite pushed for time
today.
Nice. All right.
Um still Chenzi is floating around. So,
if anybody is like not brave enough to
to tell me, but is to tell her,
she'll help.
Um so, let's have a quick look at what
you've just um imported.
Uh this is historical race data from the
sport F1. It has everything about
drivers races constructors
everything. It's awesome. Um
the people at Ergast have done a lot of
work to like put it in the shape, um and
we have just nicked it.
You can explore a little slice of this,
which I would suggest, by going to the
next slide and clicking on
uh this link.
And it'll take you to our graph
explorer. And it may look a little bit
different to this. Every time you reload
the screen, the graph is laid out in a
different way, but the data will be the
same. And this is not like all of the
data or anything like that. It's just a
comprehensive slice. So, uh for example,
if we dive in on
uh a driver,
Lewis Hamilton,
we can see
that he belongs to the class driver.
Classes are in green, instances are in
purple, and then he has a bunch of these
properties. So, if for example, later
on, you want to access the forename of a
driver,
you'll need to know that the way that we
do this is with the property driver
underscore forename.
Hopefully, that's uh not too difficult.
And uh yeah, just if you if you want,
keep these tabs open and like refer back
to them as and when, cuz
uh the exercises later will be sort of
fill-in-the-gap type exercises,
um and
it will be helpful, or we we often find
it's helpful,
to sort of refer back and like pinch
parts where you need them.
>> Awesome.
I've just managed to catch up to where
I'm supposed to be at this point.
So,
thank you.
We started a little bit late, so I was a
bit worried about time, but I think
we're we're we're back to it. So, I'm
going to take a minute.
Do we have any questions at this point?
Cuz I've really thrown a lot at you
very, very quickly.
Yeah?
>> I have a technical question.
>> Yeah, please.
>> You said a lot of stuff, but you didn't
say OWL. We're not going to
>> We are going to touch OWL. We're going
to We're going to look at uh four OWL
axioms. They're pretty basic. Um
and the reason for that is
we're we're going to focus on Datalog.
And everything you can do in OWL, you
can do in Datalog.
But then you can also do loads more
stuff.
Um and at least I personally find
Datalog much, much easier to work with.
The syntax is uh intentionally close to
SPARQL. So, if you can write SPARQL
queries, you should be able to write, or
at least very quickly pick up Datalog.
Whereas OWL Are you familiar with OWL?
Yeah. So, the syntax can be uh like
challenging sometimes. Um and a lot of
the time you end up going through a tool
like Protégé or others um that are
also a challenge
to work with.
Um so, yeah. We We are going to touch on
that because it it is the standard.
People do like it because it is the
standard. Um but yeah, we'll we'll be
we'll be focusing on on Datalog.
Right. So, before we jump into reasoning
at all, we're going to cover three uh
SPARQL queries.
They're going to get uh much harder very
quickly. Uh Uh, and you will hopefully
see
uh what I mean by that, because the
first one is just the the basic
select query, the most fundamental query
that you can write.
Um,
some of you Anyone who has written
SPARQL will recognize this,
um,
because they write it all the time.
Um, but anyone who hasn't, there are a
few key components of this that we need
to cover to make sure you kind of are
familiar with all of this going forward.
Um,
this is where the exercises start. So,
if anyone is follow following along from
slide 20,
uh, there's going to be a link in the
bottom right corner to the open in the
console. You can go ahead and click
that.
And it will
open in the console.
That's fine.
Don't know why I'm whispering.
There's a There's a QR code there. Give
that a scan. Um, someone will send you
uh, a package.
Um, the instruct The instructions start
on slide 10. So, uh, hopefully, you
should be able to follow along, but Chen
Zi is also available to like
help you through that if if you need it.
So, just like stick your hand up.
Um,
cool. So,
where were we?
There's a few key parts to this, and
we're going to go through them one by
one.
Um, but they're they're fairly simple.
The first is the select keyword, uh, at
the very top left. This just describes
what type of query uh, we're writing,
and what AnzoGraph needs to do with the
information that you're providing it.
Um, select is just a find and return
query. There are
uh, many other types available, but
select is the only one that we're going
to be covering.
Um,
because the others are are a bit more
advanced, to be to be honest. But again,
if you want to like talk about those,
uh,
stick around afterwards, and we we
definitely can.
Underneath it is the where clause, and
this is um, where we describe the
pattern in the graph that we're looking
for.
And um in this case, we're trying to
find all of our data. So, the the
function of this query as a whole is to
return our entire data set.
So, not perhaps the most um functional,
but definitely very, very important.
The pattern we're describing here is
uh
a triple pattern. So, in within this
where clause, you can make the graph
pattern as
uh complex as you like, but here it's
just a pattern of a triple because all
of our data is in triples, and uh we
want to find and match all of our data.
In the subject, predicate, and object
position of this triple, we've used
three variables
uh given by the question mark and then
any any characters you want afterwards.
We've called it S, P, and O um
kind of by convention, but because it's
like
convenient for us.
And this is just a variable uh in every
position of the triple, which of course
would match every triple that we have.
The final piece of the puzzle is the uh
all the stuff next to select. Uh and
these are the output variables. So, of
our of the pattern that we described
within the where clause,
a lot of the time, this is going to be
like huge and very complicated, and it's
going to involve pieces that actually
we're not interested in in seeing.
And so, on the output, we just put the
variables that we actually want to
return in the results table.
In this case though, we do want all of
it because we want all of our data. So,
we have S, P, and O on the output.
If you go ahead and click run,
you will uh see in the results
uh
all of your data. So,
uh again, probably not super helpful as
a as a visual result set, um but it is
there for when you need to sort of
export everything or or whatever.
Query number two
is about counting our drivers races. So,
uh, we're taking a pretty big leap here.
There's a bunch of new stuff that we're
going to throw at you all at once. But
again,
uh, I'll I'll sort of go through it bit
by bit to to try and
keep everybody, um,
yeah, up to speed.
There are now two links.
Uh, one says open in console, one says
answer.
Uh, you'll notice that there are some
gaps. These three under underline, this
will give you an error. Um, anyone who's
following along,
please click open in console and you
will get one that is not filled in.
Um, and I would really appreciate you
trying to fill in these gaps yourself.
Uh, I'm going to go through it on the
fly. So, um, I'm afraid we don't have
time to sort of sit around and mull with
it.
Uh, but if you do get stuck, click on
the answer and it will have, uh, a
complete one for you.
Uh, I'm going to cheat a little bit and
go straight to the answer
so that we can all see it together.
Uh, cuz again, there are a few key
parts.
You'll notice that the where clause is
getting a little bit more complicated.
We're now, uh, using specific
predicates. So, result driver and result
race are specific predicates in our
data.
Um, and we are looking for, um,
as I said, the drivers and the number of
races that they've raced in.
So, for this, we need to find the
drivers, associate them with a race, and
in our data, in the sort of snippet that
you might have been exploring earlier,
we have to do this via a result. So, a
result is associated with a driver and a
race. And now we have to link the two.
So,
the output also looks a little bit
different here because we are returning
driver as you might expect but we're
also doing this count
counting the instances of the variable
race and saving that count as race
count.
So combined we're returning the drivers
and a count of the race.
Pretty simple.
The final couple of pieces are at the
bottom here.
The first is group by driver. We need to
tell Alex how to group these counts
because we don't just want a count of
all the races that have ever been raced.
We need to give it the context that
you know a driver is the thing we want
to group by because it doesn't know what
a driver is doesn't know what a race is.
So we have to say group the count by
race by drivers and then we will get the
total number of races per driver.
Finally we're going to order by
descending race race count just to give
us a bit of a more usable list.
So if we click run on that
we have drivers on the left and their
race count on the right.
Was anyone ever able to follow along
with that?
Yeah?
Awesome. Cool.
Anyone else?
It was a pretty pretty Yeah? Ah,
awesome. Great.
Anybody anybody not able to follow along
with that?
Wanted to but couldn't.
Sorry. That was somebody still waiting
on that email.
That's that's a bit of a blocker I'm not
going to lie. Sorry.
>> Yeah, sorry. I have a company personal
>> Yeah, sorry.
Um
Okay dokey. So
the final query we're going to look at
today
is around calculating a win percentage.
So hopefully you can see why we've um
admittedly rapidly built this up uh over
the last couple of queries. We're now
going to compute something that is
actually valuable to us. Um the win
percentage uh for each of our drivers.
And that of course involves counting the
total number of races, but also the
total number of wins. But there are a
couple of complications here.
So let's
uh
dive through these one by one.
Okay-dokey. So,
we're looking for drivers and their win
percentage. So,
first and foremost, we need some
information about the drivers, their
full name and surname, so we can get a
list of names.
And then we're going to go into actually
performing these counts.
But to help us do this we need to use an
inner select query. So, you'll notice
that we have
uh another select query here. We've
opened up another set of curly brackets
and just written the same uh count
select that we did previously. So,
hopefully nothing too new there, but the
interesting thing is that it is within
another query.
And then we performed
a second count query that looks almost
the same except now we've got that the
result position order must be one. So,
it must be a win.
And we're counting these number of races
uh and saving this as a new variable
race win.
The problem here though is that this
graph pattern
um
it assumes that the driver has won a
race.
Which
sounds about right. But what if a driver
hasn't won a race? Um then they will be
excluded from this result. And the
larger query will not return them uh as
a driver at all.
Which is not what we want because
a win percentage of zero
is pretty important, particularly if
you're tracking this over time
uh and seeing seeing how that changes.
So, you'll notice we've stuck an
optional keyword in front of the second
in a select, and this just tells Aria
Fox that this next part of the query is
optional.
What it will do is
if this graph pattern is matched, it
will perform the inner select
as normal.
If it is not,
it will just leave any variables that
would have been defined, I race wins, as
undefined. It won't throw a problem,
it'll just keep on going.
That causes us a problem though, because
we now need to sort something out and do
something about our undefined variable.
Um and so we use this
uh bind
to uh
bind our unfound undefined variables.
To help us, we use the coalesce
function. Uh and what that does is it
takes an input variable,
if it has a defined value, it just
returns that value.
If it doesn't, it returns the second
argument, which in this case we put a
zero because we know
if this race wins wasn't defined, it was
because they didn't have a win, which
means their race wins should be zero.
And so we bind final sorry, race wins
final as the output of this coalesce.
The last thing we have to do is actually
perform our calculation
of the percentage, which is pretty
simple now, just race wins final divided
by race count, save it as percentage.
So, we're returning
a whole bunch of stuff on the output,
but just we're we're expecting a list of
names, their race count, race wins, and
the percentage.
So, if we go down,
uh rerun this,
we can see that we have um Lee Wallet at
the top with a 50% uh race wins.
Pretty impressive, but he's only got two
total race counts.
Uh and then folks like Hamilton
uh a little bit further down, but 266
uh race counts and a 35% uh win rate,
which if there are any F1 fans in the
room, you'll know that's not true
anymore.
Um
if you'll well, remember back to the
beginning, we got you to import up to
2020 the data file. Uh that's because
this is true of uh
up until the year 2020.
The later the later years, '21 through
'23, will uh will deal with in a little
bit, but there's a there's a very good
reason why
uh we split that and yeah, that that
will all be revealed
uh with time to come.
So,
that was the lightning round of
foundations. What is semantic reasoning
and the basic queries. Yeah, we've got a
question over here.
Um so, how are we Sorry, let me make
sure I've understood this.
Is this about this?
That's right. So, they're all part of
our data. So, if we go back to this
um
like graph exploration of our our data,
which it was on on one of the earlier
slides. The there's a link to this. I
think it's maybe
slide 14.
Give or take.
Um this is the data that exists in our
data store. So, we we have imported
this. We have made Well, actually Ergast
made these choices
um that we have now adopted.
So, now if we want to access any of
these things, so for example, we want to
access a driver's first name, we have to
use the predicate driver underscore full
name. And same for same for the others,
but yeah.
Okay.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Fair question.
Uh
let's have a look at
another person.
So, here is another driver called
Battle.
And we can
So, this this is just a tiny little
slice.
Um
and so there are there are about 200
drivers in total.
Uh I don't want to show all of them
because it would be a mess, but um
yeah, this is this is sort of how your
graph
actually is, right? But no, great great
question.
No, no, it's not not at all. Honestly.
Any any other questions?
So, that's the kind of
the fundamentals done. Hopefully, we all
sort of share
uh at least this basic level of
understanding now.
Um
that's going to enable us to to do some
reasoning.
Mhm.
Uh
so, this is an instance.
Yeah. So,
sorry, I should have explained that. Um
the purple nodes here are instances of
classes, the green nodes are classes.
All the other stuff is uh like
properties. So, it could be, you know,
these are
strings whatever.
Cool.
So, onto a little bit of OWL as as
promised, we have four axioms to cover.
The first two are concerned with
properties, the second two with classes.
And
um
yeah, this is where we're going to start
adding new data to the data store.
So,
everything we've done so far is just
querying for
existing data. Now, we're going to start
adding stuff um based off these these
axioms.
Um
this is where it starts to get a little
bit more complicated. So, uh again, if
if anybody has any questions, please
ask. Uh I am going to also go through
them quite quickly. So, I really
like anticipate confusion and like
people not not knowing what's going on,
but it's quite difficult to judge uh in
advance what your level is. So,
please jump in with questions, and I can
kind of tailor this
to you.
Yeah, well, that's the hope.
Um again, we're going to start with some
some very basics. What is OWL? Well, OWL
uh is an axiom used to write axioms and
ontologies.
And well, what are those things? Well,
ultimately, axioms are just assertions
of truth. So, they are just true
statements uh that OWL reasoners to make
some inferences. So,
like data might have been uh Lewis
Hamilton has the first name Lewis.
That's that's a fact. That's a very
specific fact. Um an axiom might be
uh all drivers are people, which is
still a fact, but it's much more
general.
An OWL reasoner will then take that and
say, "Oh, this thing is a driver,
therefore, it's also a person."
Pretty simple.
Ontologies are just collections of
axioms.
Um there are lots of definitions, and
other people here will give you other
ones. They will probably be right as
well, but at their core
it's it's that simple.
Um it is just just a collection of
axioms, so it's even though it's this
sort of scary term, um you don't really
need to be that scared of it.
OWL is the standard way that ontologies
and axioms are described.
Easy peasy.
We'll be using a syntax called Turtle,
but there are other syntaxes available.
Um
for anyone who knows
what that is, you know. For anyone who
doesn't, don't worry about it.
And why do we need this? So, we've
already shown a little bit about um what
reasoning can do in general, but OWL
specifically uh helped us out with a few
things.
And uh this
uh family of drivers helps us
show why it's necessary.
So, uh these guys are all from the the
Fittipaldi family. There's four of them.
They were all Formula 1 drivers at
different times. That's why they're in
our data set. Uh and we have this blank
node here who is uh Pietro's mother. She
was not a Formula 1 driver, so she's not
in our data set. She's just a blank
node.
Um
but you can see that this is
a bit of a mess.
And if we look at what sort of queries
we'd write, we can see
um
why that, you know, what why this causes
some problems.
Um
if we look at Emerson and Wilson at the
top,
these guys are brothers.
But the data that we have about them is
that Wilson has sibling Emerson.
So, if we write a query that says, "Who
is Emerson's siblings?"
The uh or already Fox will say, "Emerson
has no siblings." Because that's not
what the data says.
Likewise, if we say, "Who is Wilson's
brother?"
Already Fox will say, "Wilson has no
brothers." Even though we read this and
we know that these are true.
This is
a huge problem, especially if you're
combining several data sets.
Perhaps, you know, we've got a has child
relationship here between Wilson and
this other Fittipaldi.
Maybe one data set talks about children,
the other talks about parents. And now
you're combining the two and you have
two ways to talk about the same thing,
but no real way to deal with it. So,
either
you have to write a query that accounts
for all possibilities, which
you're probably not going to do cuz that
would be a pain to maintain and you're
likely to make mistakes.
Or you go through a pretty lengthy and
uh
difficult transformation step where you
kind of do your very best to account for
all of these things
uh and to, you know, either change one
to the other or import others or
whatever.
Um that does work, but it is hard, it is
costly, and it's pretty rigid. So,
if you make a mistake,
often you have to start again.
Um if you introduce new data, you
obviously have to do the whole
transformation all over again.
Um but we can just not do any of that if
we choose to use owl reasoning.
Um and we'll see in a moment that we can
import uh sorry, infer
uh like inverse relationships, for
example. So, every time we see has
child, we can add has parent in the
other direction. And it is as simple as
adding in an axiom. And now
every time we add in a new has child,
additionally, this has parent will be
inferred. So, straight away, we can just
query for has parent even though our
explicit data said nothing about that.
That kind of that way of managing
is very, very
easy and is sort of one command rather
than like anything else. And you can
keep track of what you've inferred. So,
again, if you make a mistake, very
easily take it all out,
make make adjustments, add it back. And
again, we'll we'll see this in a second.
Yeah.
So, you can't just import an edge um as
as far as I'm aware, but you can
Sorry, let me let me make sure I've
understood your question. Can you like
rephrase that?
Mhm.
Sorry, that's I've
Yes, I understand where the confusion is
coming from. What I should have said is
if you add a triple that includes this
has child relationship, then a new
triple will be added with the same two
nodes.
Exactly. Exactly.
Yeah.
Mhm.
You certainly can. Yeah. Um
we I won't be showing that,
but this is actually an abridged version
of a different workshop that I sometimes
give that's 4 hours.
It's included in that one.
So, if you fancy that, come along later.
Um but but yeah, very good question. And
in case anybody didn't hear that,
um we can make we can sort of chain
these
axioms or make them as complicated as we
want them to. So, we could, for example,
add um has uncle being a uh father who
has a brother
parent who has a brother. Um
So,
excellent segue.
Um oh, no.
Almost an excellent segue.
The first thing I'm going to say before
we get on to uh these axioms is um
Protégé is a tool that you can use to
write axioms. It takes care of a lot of
this for you. It's free and open source.
So, we would always point people here if
you're going to do this.
However, there's a sort of caveat to all
of this is you you don't need an
ontology.
Um I can't stress that enough. Um we say
this all the time because
it has happened so many times where
people have come to us. They have this
beautiful ontology and they say, "Now I
want to like do something with this."
So, I great. You're you're keen. This is
awesome.
Um
and then they actually start writing
queries and they actually start like
importing data and they realize that
their whole ontology that they spent
months on
isn't supporting the queries that they
want to run and like isn't supporting
the data that they really have.
And when it's something that you don't
actually need,
um
that's like a huge waste of time and
it's very frustrating and it sets back
the project.
And there's a good reason why people do
this is because in SQL, you need a
schema. And so, people who have
traditionally come from there or have
like picked up habits from that
background, they come and they they rush
to an ontology, but that's not the case
um with a graph. You you don't need any
of that. You can just start with data,
start with queries, and then when when
you hit a roadblock like you're
combining data sets that need some
transformation, that's when you head to
your ontology editor, that's when you
start supporting the queries that you
want to write.
Cool.
So,
now coming to your question, how do we
actually make these inferences?
Um with axioms. So, this is the first
axiom set and as promised, it's around
properties. In this case,
it is
uh has father is a sub property of
parent. So, this this is an axiom. We
will come come to rules in a little bit,
but I want to
Rules are way better.
Um, but we'll
yeah, we we kind of need to set set the
sort of historical foundations cuz
everybody uses OWL
and has done for a for a long time.
So,
in this case we're saying that has
father and has mother are both
subproperty of has parent. Hopefully you
can see that I've highlighted the like
key parts of this axiom because the
syntax of OWL is quite confusing, or at
least I find that there's some stuff
there that can mislead you. So, um, if
that's the case, just focus on the
colored boxes.
Um,
but on the right you can see what
actually happened in our data store. So,
we have our again Emerson and Pietro and
uh, this woman in between.
And you can see that our explicit data
is Pietro has mother
uh, his mother. Uh, the mother has
father Emerson. And that's in sort of
grayed out uh,
gray.
In the blue is what we've inferred. So,
you can see that with our axioms it has
found has parent and then between the
two same nodes in the same direction,
our data box has inferred this has
parent relationship. And it has happened
for both
uh, has father and has mother. So, now
we have two has parent relationships
between our our nodes. So, if we're
writing a query, now we can query for
has parent instead of saying, "Show me
all the fathers and show me all the
mothers."
Hopefully
that's very straightforward.
Um, does anybody have
any questions about this or OWL in
general?
Yeah.
>> So,
how long is a open world assumption?
>> Uh, I
>> And then how long is
>> I think it depends on which
uh shard he use. Um
RDFox is closed world assumption. Uh and
so so what this means, open and close
close world assumptions effectively
means if something is missing, do you
assume it's um
missing or wrong. And closed world means
uh if something is missing, we assume
it's incorrect. And we'll we'll come on
to uh feature that relies on that
heavily later and and this is
why we've gone down this path.
Um but it is it's a really important
part of all of this that actually a lot
of people miss. So fantastic question.
>> is
is closed world or
>> Yeah, closed world. So all of what we do
is closed world. Um and so one of the
benefits of that is everything in your
data store is guaranteed to be
consistent and accurate with the rules
and the data that you have. So if you
have
uh a legal database, say,
and you do some inference,
you need to know
that the things that have been inferred
are correct. And with the closed world
assumption,
you can sort of take that guarantee um
because it's not going to say, "Well,
this was missing, so maybe it's true,
maybe it's not."
Does that answer your question?
>> But
if you if you if you benefit from open
world, you can
>> Yeah.
>> use that log.
>> That's true. Yeah. So so it's not this
very much is not a one's better or one's
worse. It's
depending on your use case.
Um
we find in practice that the kind of
guaranteed truth is
is more important, but yeah, if if
you're if the thing that you're working
on specifically needs the open world
assumption,
then yeah, I'm afraid this is not going
to going going you any favors. Um
but
yeah.
Um
right.
Two more things I want to say about uh
this axiom set. One is this is not data
validation. So, this will not stop you
doing anything. Um this will just add
new data to the data store. So, these
blue facts are have really been added to
your store. This is not going to
um sort of restrict by any means that
sort of father has to be a subproperty
of parent. If you try and do something
weird,
it'll this will let you.
There are tools that will will stop you.
Uh they are called Shackle or again Data
Log. So, if you want to do data
validation or uh some kind of constraint
violation stuff, um
that is very much possible and is hugely
important in enterprise, uh but we're
not going to cover it. So, if you want
to talk about that again,
stick around at the end. We can have
chat. But, uh it's very important to
remember that this just adds data. It's
not sort of stopping you.
The second thing that I really want to
point out here is because I mean, this
kind of gives it away, but in these
axioms,
the inferred information is trackable.
So, RDFox keeps track of exactly what
has been inferred and exactly what is
explicit. And that's why managing this
is so much easier because to get this
picture, I've just run one command that
is import
this axiom set.
If I find I've made a mistake, I just
unimport the axiom set.
These previously inferred uh
relationships are removed and I'm back
to my base state. So, I don't have to
worry about um you know, really trying
to keep track of stuff like I would if I
just do a simple insert statement where
I have to remember, oh yeah, last week I
inserted this has parent thing that
wasn't already in my data. Maybe I made
a mistake Um and now I have to go
through and find all of this stuff that
I have to now remove. Yeah.
>> How do you
test
um
that the axioms you put in
uh
are
sort of correct? And you cuz you said
you had to remove them. Is there a way
of sort of
running the same que- queries without
those axioms and then with them or do
you have to actually remove them from
the database?
>> Um
>> testing
It's question.
>> So that is a fantastic question. Um yes,
there there is a there are a few good
ways to do this.
Um
the the one
I would point you to is a a feature
called delta queries, which um
effectively runs the same query twice,
once before import, once after import,
and shows you the delta.
Um and they're they're great because
they are super efficient. So it's it is
just I mean it's a little bit more than
the delta, but it's like a very small
computation.
Yeah.
>> We'll be
talking about it, but I am a
general AI engineer. My question is that
I'm a lazy programmer. I I I don't know
how you do it, but are there any general
AI tools that can extract axio- axioms
from texts?
>> Um
um
No.
Not that I know of. Uh yeah, I'm sorry.
Um as a as a general AI engineer, that's
probably not what you want to hear, but
the the sort of
the
I don't know how to phrase this, but
the real power in these axioms, in these
rules, is that they are encoded expert
knowledge or domain knowledge. So all
right, has father being a sub property
of has parent, pretty easy, right?
>> for the SME, right?
>> You could.
>> give it like to just to correct it to
validate, that's it.
>> You You could, but
some of our clients, a lot of our
clients use these to do
very complicated stuff. So, you're using
several layers of rules that are all
doing very very specific things. And the
reason why
they use it is because and and they
don't use or
separately use like GenAI is because
the answers you get are guaranteed to be
accurate. So, according to your rule set
and according to your data
the results are true
with with 100% accuracy. And
the second you introduce
um
you know, LLMs or whatever, and that's
really important, but at a different
step.
There it introduces this
sort of shadiness where
I don't know, say you dropped to 99%
which frankly would be impressive.
But
going down from 100 to 99 is
a huge step, right? Where you know, 99
to 98
not so bad.
>> That's what you do with all
>> It does depend what you do. But a lot of
what a lot of where people would
introduce LLMs is sort of at a later
stage where you're like accessing the
data. So, you're accessing
sort of a a foundationally
guaranteed correct source that you then
access via
LLM or you know,
do then something with that data that's
like GenAI. Um
but yeah, typically or not not
typically, we would always encourage an
expert to write this.
But if you don't want to
there's nothing stopping you.
So, you know, you could ask ChatGPT to
write you an OWL axiom and it would.
>> One thing is the power times the
efficiency. It's all about money.
>> Go for it. Yeah, yeah. I mean, really go
for it. Like if if if the trade-off for
you is worth it. So, that like you don't
need that accuracy and and there are use
cases where you don't.
Stick it in. Like it there's nothing
stopping you.
Hey?
>> A gap in the market.
>> Yeah, maybe. Maybe.
Um but yeah, we we would we would very
much encourage people to
uh
to yeah.
Um
Uh
Cool. Sorry, I thought I was way behind,
but I'm actually on time.
>> say
>> No, no, no, no, no. No, no, please.
Honestly, like the the questions are are
fantastic.
>> I have a question about the multiple
multiple axioms referring to the same
properties.
>> Yep.
>> If you have many axioms that are applied
sequentially and then you want to go
about removing them and if say three
axioms have the same property, is that
being tracked and
can you then query by for a given
property which axioms or is it
is it handled in a graceful way?
>> So, that's a fantastic question. You've
jumped ahead of me. I was going to talk
about this with the next axiom set, but
I'll get to it now. Um the question was
uh effectively
how do we um manage duplicates? So,
you know, what if what if has parent is
inferred in two different ways by two
different axioms uh and how do you deal
with procedure? So, if I have an axiom
that relies on another axiom um is there
a scenario in which the sort of second
one
can be inferred first and then the first
one meaning that I don't end up with
this full set, is that right?
>> Yeah, well, like conflicting ones
overriding like
>> Yeah.
So, the the short answer is you don't
have to worry about it. Um the long
answer is
um
if there are several axioms that in
infer the same uh property
RDFox will infer one that that singular
triple once and recognize that there are
three sort of supporting pillars.
Obviously, we've been talking about
removing them. So, if you then remove
one of those pillars,
um the other two still hold. So, this
fact remains. So, it's it's not as
though
like this one is inferring this, it's
that it is inferred by all three. And as
long as one remains,
the fact remains.
As far as procedure goes, it's the same
deal.
Um
ArchiFox will figure out which order
they need to go in. Um and that is
particularly important if they're sort
of
self-referential or cyclic. Um that's
another question we get all the time,
what if sort of something infers
something that infers something and then
you back round to the beginning one. Um
it will infer the cycle and then stop.
And
this is sort of calculated in a very
like clever way that means
the entire set is always inferred. So,
it will keep trying until no more it is
being added. So,
um yeah, no no worries there.
But yeah, another another fantastic
question.
Any more?
Yeah.
>> Real world question. Out of all your
customers,
>> Yeah.
>> how many of them use these OWL axioms
and how many do not?
>> Roughly.
>> I mean,
>> Everybody?
>> almost everyone.
Um the the sort of truth of the
situation is most people use both data
log and OWL. So, most people have a um
like an ontology that they like and they
use and um
then use data log rules to do like
aggregates or negation or these like
filters or whatever, you know, the the
more like business-oriented um
reasoning.
But
the ontology still stands. Um and
sometimes it's just useful.
Uh sometimes it's a legacy thing,
but it's it's yeah.
>> Are you going to talk about when to use
data log versus when to use OWL?
>> Yeah.
So,
um
as a sort of
an intro to that
ontological reasoning, um probably the
easiest way is to do it with that OWL if
it's a big ontology. And if you if
you're sort of mapping that out and you
have an ontologist, which is kind of how
a lot of people approach this in in
practice,
um they might build it up in something
like Protégé, which handles some of that
for you.
Great. Stick it in. You're done.
Um you could do that in data log if you
want. And
who knows, maybe we'll get to a point
where actually more people are trained
with data log and that becomes easier
and quicker and all the rest of it, in
which case there may be a shift. But,
you know, that that there's nothing
there's no reason why that wouldn't
happen.
Um but then there's a a load of stuff
that OWL can't do.
Um
and whenever you run into that, which it
is
frequently, that's when you uh turn to
data log.
Yeah.
>> How many
In average, how many axioms does one
graph usually have?
>> Uh I mean, how long's a piece of string?
Like, how many do you need? You know, if
if you need one, one. Uh if you need
a million,
use a million. It It won't be, but, you
know, it is
entirely dependent on the use case.
Um
but
yeah.
I think
>> That's not much also so the question is
not that much usually, right?
>> Yeah, I think in our for the for the F1
demo that I don't know if anybody
actually did click on that, but anyone
who did, I think we have about three or
400.
Um so, yeah. Um so, you know, a a fair
number, but those weren't written by
hand. So, we we didn't we didn't sit and
write these out. We used Protégé, which
is is an efficiency tool um and is is
much better. So, yeah, cool.
Um
So,
I don't know if that gives you an
aspect, but it's
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> like it really is
like if you don't need an ontology, use
none, you know? Don't don't don't use
any at all.
Um
>> If you don't need an ontology, yeah, so
no.
>> So, yeah.
Cool.
Um
Right. Axiom set two.
Inverse properties. So, this is similar
to
uh the last axiom set, except now we are
inferring uh
a relationship in the opposite direction
to one that already already exists. So,
in this case, we are looking at uh
result driver and driver result. So, our
explicit data in gray is this result has
result driver this driver.
With this axiom that just says result
driver is an inverse of driver result,
we are inferring in the opposite
direction between the same two nodes,
driver result.
Pretty pretty self-explanatory.
Um this is the sort of thing where we're
looking at parent and child that's
really really useful.
And
um
part of the reason why that is so useful
is bringing this right back to start. Um
these are just statements of truth. So,
there is no directionality to these
axioms.
Result driver is an inverse of driver
result means driver result is an inverse
of result driver. So, in this case, uh
result driver was our explicit data. So,
driver result was inferred, but it could
very easily have been the other way
around where um result driver, sorry,
driver result was our explicit data and
result driver was inferred.
And that's really important when you're
combining two data sets. You don't want
to have to write two axioms that just do
the same thing in different directions.
>> So, if you have an age without driver,
do you add another age?
>> Yeah. Perfect.
Um and again, this is great. You don't
have to worry about cycles. You don't
have to worry about duplicates. You
don't have to do any of that because of
the procedure discussion before.
>> Very good philosophy.
>> Well, is there ever a concern about
are these axioms adding loads and loads
of triples?
Is there a philosophy of
>> Mhm.
>> what to precompute by these axioms
versus like writing complicated SPARQL
queries like you did at the very
beginning?
>> Yeah, totally. Um and again, that that
depends on your need. So, um
it's unusual.
I don't think we've ever come into a
situation where uh people weren't able
to
like
sort of buy a machine big enough to
house their data. Um in in this day and
age, you can buy
like obscene machines for next to
nothing on AWS. Um so,
it's it's not a
a sort of hard limit, but of course, it
does cost money. So, you do want to be
uh conservative about what you do and
not just add stuff because you can.
Um that being said,
the like overhead of these triples is
not massive. So, I think
I mean, it it it again, it entirely
depends on your your axioms and your
your data and the rest of it, but we we
save between like 60 and 100 bytes per
triple. So, you're not adding
vast amounts.
Um
but
you know, yeah. Don't don't don't be
silly with it.
Um
it won't sort of this kind of thing um
won't get you into like an infinite loop
of you know,
this won't in infinitely uh insert
queries. Um uh sorry, infinitely insert
um relationships. You can write uh
rules. I think I'm not sure if you do it
with axioms, but you can write rules
that will run infinitely. Um
but
there are kind of
uh
like warnings along the way. So, um if
you do that, it's because you've made a
mistake uh effectively um
or done it intentionally but with the
sort of intention that it will run
forever because you want to stress the
system.
Um
There's one more thing I was going to
say on that. There was an out of Oh,
yeah, that's the one. So,
it depends
really on how quick you want your final
system to be. So, we have
uh some use cases where they need
answers instantly or as as near to real
time real time as possible. In that
case,
memory's not a problem. They they buy a
huge machine, add all the data, and then
just run a query that is like near
instant.
Um if it doesn't matter, maybe you're
not running a sort of uh client-facing
system then
you know, be much conservative, write
more complex queries,
have it take a little bit longer. Um
it really is
in in your hands to decide that
trade-off. Um but it is unfortunately a
sort of
inherent trade-off of of these systems.
>> Why don't you actually Why don't you
vectorize it all and do a vector search?
That would be much faster.
>> So, you can do a vector search if you
want, but they're just sort of uh again,
it's sort of pros and cons. So, you
we have a we have a RAG demo that uh
uses a vector database to vectorize
uh some of the data,
but you lose the reasoning piece cuz you
can't do reasoning over a vector
database.
Um so,
>> You can combine
>> So, you can combine the two, and that's
what we do in the RAG demo.
Uh you again, there are sort of
trade-offs by introducing a new
technology. You have to connect them.
There's another point of failure,
another point of maintenance, that sort
of thing. So,
it's
at this point we sort of get into the
like
the the weighing of architecture, which
is way beyond
what what I am qualified to talk about.
But effectively
it's your choice.
>> How about the future?
>> Uh, this one, reasoning?
>> Do you make this?
>> Uh, like vector search?
>> I don't know how we do this in in your
technology.
>> So, we we don't offer a vector search.
So, so nothing in in RDFox is uh a
vector database, but
uh you can like connect to one
um and
do it that way. So.
>> Uh, I know it's not that really
possible.
>> Mhm. Yeah.
>> It exists.
>> Yeah, sorry. But,
uh like
we've used like we've we've done some
stuff with like Chroma DB, I think is a
vector database. Yeah, getting thumbs
up. So, yeah, we So,
it is possible if you if you want to do
that. Um
yeah.
Cool.
Uh
any other questions?
This is great. This is like the slide.
Yeah?
>> Are you going to talk about
performance? Like what
axioms would kill performance?
>> Uh, what axioms would kill performance?
Um
>> You can have as many as you want
running but
>> Yeah.
>> it's uh
it does cost, right?
>> Uh, it there's an upfront cost. So, at
the point of that you import the axiom,
there is uh like a materialization stage
where all the all the facts that would
that will be inferred by that axiom get
added to the store. So, if you're
writing an axiom that adds
a million facts, that's going to take a
million facts worth of computation.
After that,
you're just running queries. So, it is
that there's no additional computation
overhead. It's just the the query.
>> The query already ran the
the reasoner.
>> Yeah.
>> That's that's stored in the memory.
>> Yeah. So, it stays in memory. So, yeah,
AllegroGraph is an in-memory store,
which again
20 years ago would have been a massive
problem, and that's why we didn't have
any clients 20 years ago. But these
days, you can buy a terabyte of RAM on
AWS and store whatever you want, and
it's lightning quick.
So.
Do you have a follow-up question, or was
that
fantastic?
>> So, is there
a comparison between OWL and you running
Datalog?
>> Mhm.
>> Which is by the way SWRL.
That is a subset of Datalog.
>> So, not quite, actually. SWRL is sort of
like an
So, SWRL is a another rule language for
the for those who don't know, and it's
kind of like an an in-between point. So,
it's a little bit more expressive than
OWL, but doesn't really do a lot of the
stuff that we want it to. So, it's
almost there, but then Datalog goes
like another leap further,
um and allows you to do loads more
again. So, we do support SWRL, and what
actually happens within AllegroGraph
itself, whenever you import axioms or
import SWRL, they get translated into
Datalog and then imported, cuz Datalog
is sort of a a coverall that then does
does these other things, too.
So.
>> So,
the the performance of running a
reasoner in OWL
and compared to Datalog, that would run
also much faster.
>> Uh if you're running reasoning, it would
it would be the same because um on
import, you know, you you get an OWL
axiom, it's just literally translated to
Datalog, then the Datalog's imported.
So actually it's
it it's literally running the Datalog.
So, they they would be they'd be the
same.
Cool. Thanks.
Um right, last two.
uh
axioms I'm going to breeze through cuz
I'm a little bit tight um on time and I
want to get to the data lock cuz that
seems to be where a lot of the questions
are anyway. So, these last two um
axioms are about classes. So, we've
looked at relationships. Now, classes,
in this case we're going to use um a
union, which is where you get to say one
thing or another or another. And we're
going to say the class podium
is equal or is an equivalent class to uh
anything that is uh that has a result
position order one, two, or three. So,
in Formula 1, for those who don't know,
uh it's said that you finished on the
podium if you finished first, second, or
third. So, we are literally just saying
if my result has position order one,
two, or three,
then it is equivalent to being the class
of a podium.
Um
I'm not going to go through the syntax
because it's complicated and I don't
have time. But, if anybody want
if anybody wants to to talk about it,
come come Yeah, it's in the PDF.
Yeah PDF.
Um likewise, axiom set is uh axiom set
four is similar.
Um but this time we're looking at class
intersections. So, this is where we say
one thing and another. Um in Formula 1,
before race day, uh they have a kind of
uh fastest lap competition, and whoever
finishes uh the day with the fastest lap
is said to have finished on pole. And
that means on race day they get to start
first. So, um actually being like having
won a race and being a pole sitter, um
both are pretty pretty important things.
Um and like
uh they're they're very desirable. So,
to be a race winner and pole sitter is a
really cool thing. So, we're now making
this uh super class almost
that is race winner and pulsator
um where if a driver is both a race
winner and pulsator, it is then inferred
that they are also a race winner and
pulsator.
Uh again giving you this other way to
query directly for what used to be two
things.
Any questions on
the classes? I know that was like a
30-second thing, so
good luck.
>> So, you have like classes, sub classes,
super classes, and
>> Mhm.
>> same classes or equal classes.
>> Yes.
>> Equivalent classes, sorry.
>> So, just just yeah. So, you can do
um any of that
um
within OWL basically and and again
Protégé will help you manage that where
you've got uh sort of this is above this
is above this and so on.
So.
Yeah.
No? Fair question. But, that's sort of
that's where OWL stops. So, you just get
this taxonomical reasoning where you can
infer stuff about equivalent classes or
you can infer stuff about properties,
but you can't go a little bit further,
which
um
is what we'll talk about in a second,
but
we need to um import these axioms, see
what happens, and then sort of talk
about why this all happens.
Um anyone who is following along,
uh I would recommend you don't do this
cuz I'm going to undo it in a second
um because uh the datalogs going to sort
of cover all of this for us,
uh but it's important that I show you
how uh and what happens. So,
I'm going to run two commands here. The
first is to import uh the axioms in
axioms.ttl to the name graph my axioms.
Uh RDFox does support name graphs. We're
not going to talk about it. If you want
to talk about it, at the end.
Um
this is because again axioms are just
data. So, we're just importing data to a
graph.
We then have to tell AllegroGraph that
the data we've just imported is actually
an axiom and then we want you to do
something with it and we want you to
infer
all the results of those axioms into our
graph. So, the second command, import
axioms, just tells AllegroGraph that the
things in the my axioms named graphs are
in fact axioms.
So let's
>> Why why is that necessary? I mean
>> Um
>> into this triple, so you should get rid
of those axioms.
>> But also in the name graph.
>> Good question.
Pass. I don't know. Valerio, do you have
an answer to that one?
Um
>> Maybe it's three parts though.
>> Yeah, why why import them as data and
then import them as axioms? Why not just
in one step?
>> Because
Uh when you import them as data, it's
ambiguous um
what graph you want to apply them to.
>> Ah.
>> That's That's literally what it is.
>> Okay.
>> But you can import them directly in
functional style.
>> Okay.
>> And
uh you can get them
>> And you apply them to certain named
graphs, not others.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> Cool. Great question.
>> That's a good reason.
>> There you go.
>> Um so,
before I import my axioms, I'm going to
prove that I'm not cheating by running
the info command.
Um you can see on these lines here,
might be a little bit small, but we have
4 and 1/2 million facts and 4 and 1/2
million explicit facts. So, we haven't
done any reasoning. All of our data is
explicit. These are the 4 and 1/2
million that we imported right at the
beginning.
Now, I'm going to run
uh import axioms
and import axioms my axioms.
And I'm going to run info again.
And voila.
The problem Yeah.
I would think so. For for some like
common domains that there'll be like
ontologies and stuff readily available.
Um
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. So, you can you can steal
other people's ontologies and uh that
can be a huge time saver. It also means
that you may end up with stuff in there
that you don't want and it may be
lacking stuff that you do want. So, you
have to be a little bit careful about
it, but yeah, I mean a great great place
to start if you can find one that's
roughly what you want.
Yeah.
Yeah. So,
Uh
Yes.
But
uh not right now, I'm afraid. Uh off the
top of my head. But if it's something
that you're
uh particularly like interested in,
let's catch up afterwards and we can um
like try and find you something that
that that works.
Um so,
I've run I've imported my axioms uh in
two commands. So, I lied when I said
one. Um but we now have 5.8 million
title facts. So, that means we have uh
materialized 1.3 million facts
um
as as simple as that.
Um
the kind of cool part is where
I
uh take these out again.
So, if I run import axioms minus
and run info again,
we're back down to 4.5 million. So,
I've made a mistake. I've undone it all.
I'm back to my starting point. I can now
reassess my axioms. So it it is as
simple as a single command to manage
these axioms, which is just
impossible with things like import
import queries.
Um
So cleanliness I'm also going to clean
my axioms graph.
So there is nothing in my system uh
there's axioms anymore.
Um but it's worth talking about the
limitations of OWL uh because there are
some limitations. There is a reason that
there is more to the workshop.
Um
OWL
uh
it is and was fantastic
but it doesn't go nearly far enough for
most enterprise use cases because
um you know, tax not taxonomical
reasoning is a great place to start but
there are so many complications of the
real world that cannot be represented by
taxonomy.
So
functionally we need to go a little bit
further.
There are also a couple of like general
limitations. Um
one is that it doesn't
support existentials, which is this
which ties into this open closed world
assumption. So if we look at
our podium which meant being first,
second, or third
this will not be inferred in both
directions because how could it be?
If a result is second that's fine. We
know it's podium. But if our explicit
data has nothing about the position
order, it just shows this result is a
podium we don't know whether it was
first, second, or third. So we cannot
infer anything.
And actually
I breezed past it
but we got a handful of errors
here when I imported those axioms.
This is what these errors
It is
you have some axioms in here that cannot
be inferred in both directions.
Um I will not deal with uh existentials.
What I will do is infer it in one
direction, but I'm just telling you
these are exceptions. So, everything
else goes in both directions. These ones
here go in one.
Generally speaking, you'll know that
already when you write the axioms, um
but it's important still that you
are aware
if you happen to get an error like this.
Sorry, a warning like this, not an error
because it's it will still uh keep
going. Uh it's not a problem, but if you
expected it to do something
yeah.
>> What's the limitation there? Because
that's that's logical.
>> Um
>> do anything else with
>> Yeah, so it's kind of like
>> It's just you don't like warnings.
>> Yeah, if people see a warning, they're
like, "Oh, like what have I done?" And
it's like, "Actually,
it you know, it's done what you wanted
it to do, but
>> it's not as you've directed it, so you
don't like this.
>> Exactly.
>> It's a warning then.
Yeah.
Any other questions? What's
>> Oh, I had a quick question if we're
still talking about inferring things
>> Mhm.
>> in the reverse
in the reverse way. So, for instance, if
you
if you know that somebody else was in
was in the pole
>> Yeah.
>> was in first and somebody else was in
third,
okay?
>> Then they must be second.
>> And they must have been second, and then
you can do that in datalog.
>> You can do that in datalog. You'd
>> now.
>> You can't do that now.
>> Exactly.
That's
>> Nailed it.
>> going that way?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> No.
I'm not going that way.
>> that.
>> But that actually
>> That's what we wanted to know.
>> We should add that to the workshop cuz
that's a great example.
Um so, you could do that with um
datalog. So, for those who didn't catch
that, um basically, if you have
additional information that narrows down
the result, so we have, you know, in
this case
we have a result that we don't know the
position of. In the same race, we have
somebody who's come first and third, we
would read that and know that they must
have come second. You can write a rule,
a datalog rule, that would capture that
information and add it in.
Again, it relies on you having
enough additional information to fill
that gap, but as long as you do have the
supporting information, absolutely fine.
Um
Cool. Another So, kind of in the similar
vein,
um
this axiom here, where we combine pole
sitter and race winner, this is just he
is a pole sitter of any race and a race
winner of any race. That's where he gets
race winner and pole sitter, but if we
want from the same race to be a pole
sitter and a race winner,
can't do it. That It seems like a really
simple axiom, but you just can't do it
in AL.
Um
However,
in datalog, that kind of thing, same
with the the first, second, third thing,
that becomes trivial.
So, we've done
all the AL reasoning stuff.
Any questions about AL?
We had quite a few, so I'm hoping we
caught them as we went, but that That's
great.
Fantastic.
>> Oh, can I just ask
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> I guess it's kind of like last week, but
>> Cool.
>> So, you said you said
AL was really widely used, what everyone
uses. But then you also said that
because of it's not powerful enough to
cover most enterprise use cases.
>> Yeah.
>> So, what are they using it for?
>> Very good question. Um
enterprise use cases is the truth. Um
but
it comes with these downsides where
people typically come to us when they
have a speed problem.
Um and that's that's why our jumping in
point is always speed. So,
datalog does stuff
that is sort of functionally more
advanced um than sort of queries or
anything like that can offer you, but
nobody knows about that, so you can't be
like, "Oh, it does all this other cool
stuff." cuz it's like, "I don't care."
What people do care about is
I've got a system with Neontology, but
it's powering my website and it takes my
users 10 seconds to to find what they're
looking for. And I know from my web
stats that, you know, 50% of people
close the tab after 6 seconds. How can I
get it down?
We then say,
"Here you go."
>> So, speed is the entry point for you.
>> Speed is the entry point.
>> But there's a lot more power in there.
>> Absolutely.
>> And it's also it's about having
declarative logic.
>> Mhm.
>> Whereas
>> Yeah.
>> in most organizations, you could
you could model the business, but the
the complex declarative logic would end
up being the the logic would end up
being
in code.
>> That yeah, that's right.
>> got more and more complicated and the
code gets copied everywhere, and etc.
>> Yeah.
>> So, this this is really what it's about.
It's about moving that to
>> Yeah. Absolutely right. So, in case
uh people at the back didn't catch that,
there
in existing enterprise systems a lot of
the time, it would you'd query first of
all the data you need, and then perform
some like Python or whatever on top of
that to actually do the analysis, and
then serve it up to your user. But,
you're creating and having to maintain a
code base that uh is sort of a
high-skill thing. It's also like
difficult and costly, so you don't
really want to do that. Instead of doing
that, you can just have a handful of
rules that are um
like much easier to maintain, to work
with um
probably at the minute it's harder to
find the skills, but within this room,
it's probably not hard to find the
skills. So, if anyone's job hunting, uh
you know, talk to each other.
Um
cool. So,
that's
all out the way.
Um now on to Datalog.
So, in Datalog, we write rules, and they
look a little bit like this. Um I'll
show you a real example in a second cuz
this is a little bit abstract, but
basically
the rule is split broadly into three
sections. You have the inference symbol
in the middle.
Everything before the inference symbol
is called the head. Everything after is
called the body.
And you can read this like a SPARQL
query. So, it's intentionally designed
to be like a SPARQL query
as A is true whenever B is true. So, B,
the the body here, this is your graph
pattern.
Wherever you find this graph pattern,
A is inferred and added
to the graph.
>> So, Datalog is a tool, right?
>> Yes, it's a language. So,
>> It's a language.
>> Yeah. So, here is an actual Datalog
rule. So, maybe this clarifies that a
little bit.
We have uh a graph or we have the
inference symbol in the top right.
Everything after that is the body.
And we have this graph pattern that
connects the result to the race, the
result to the driver, and then in the
head is what we infer. So, wherever we
find this pattern, which is a pattern
that we relied on uh in the count uh in
the in the SPARQL query a lot,
um we infer a direct connection between
the driver and the race, has raced in.
So, this has raced in property is a new
property that we are adding to our
graph.
Um
>> Do you do it only for properties?
>> Uh no, you can do whatever you like. So,
um in this case, we have variables with
the question marks and data um in the
reds. In this case, all of them are
properties.
We'll see examples in a little bit that
aren't. Um but you I mean, you could do
uh like data in three positions. And
actually, if you're being lazy, that's a
way to just insert a fact. Um
I wouldn't do that. It's bad bad habits.
Uh but you can if you want. Uh and just
have nobody. So, it's just wherever
nothing is found
insert this thing, which yeah.
Probably shouldn't have said that. Don't
want you doing that. Please don't.
Um but you can.
Um
I don't know if anyone's still following
along.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Yeah?
Awesome. So,
>> So, I was wondering
>> Yeah?
Awesome. I just I I worry because it's
so quick. I worry that nobody can like
actually keep up with this, but um I'm
going to import a rule and run a query
that relies on this rule.
Um
So, unfortunately, I am back to the
terminal. So, there's no nice UI uh for
rules um at this very moment in time.
So, we're going to look at uh rule one
on the left and our query Q11
on the right.
Where is this?
Let's make that a little bit bigger.
>> So, so you use them in combination of
this all in data log.
>> Yes. So, I mean, it really depends on
your application. If I the
the few demos that I've like hacked
together, I would just use data log
because
>> Only then.
>> Uh yeah, but that's because
>> the ontology just using data log.
>> Uh so, I then wouldn't use an ontology.
Um but those are in
relatively simple use cases.
In in practice, normally, you have some
form of ontology uh
uh because somebody's worked on it or
because you found one online.
>> Okay.
>> Or really because it is what you need.
And you know, the the thing you're
modeling is an ontology.
>> Yeah.
>> And in that case,
you need an ontology cuz you're you're
modeling an ontology. Um in those
instances, yeah, you export that in OWL
from Protégé and then import it to audio
fox. But again that that'll be turned
into data log so it's kind of like
everything everything leads to data log
in the end.
Um
but yeah, in in practice I'd probably
use both.
Um so yeah.
Here's our rule. It infers this has
raced in uh predicate between uh
whatever driver it finds and whatever
race it finds
given this pattern.
We're then running this query that
relies on this has raced in property. So
we're querying something that uses the
property in our rule. Pretty easy.
To run this query we're going to use
evaluate.
Uh
what is it? Queries.
Q
Q11.rq.
So I'm going to run it first and we
should get nothing because we haven't
imported the rule yet.
>> Is that an and relationship or
>> Uh
yes. Yes. So if So the question was uh
is this an and relationship? And
so actually the answer is no because
what this is is a graph pattern. So what
you're describing is a is a pattern with
an within a graph but
you're absolutely right to assume it's
like an and because both of these have
to be true um in order to to make the
inference.
If you need like an or you can have a
couple of couple of different um rules
with the different bodies cuz they're
effectively different rules at that
point.
Um so
there goes query 11, no answers as
promised.
There's no no cheats.
Uh we're then going to import rule one
and run the query again and suddenly we
have loads of data. So or loads of
answers, I should say. So, again with
one command we've imported a rule, Audi
Fox has imported all of these queries,
all of these queries, all of this data,
and now we have our drivers and what is
it? Yeah, the races they've raced in.
So, just like that we have this new
property accessible.
Any Any questions? Yeah.
So, good question.
So, yeah, this SPARQL insert query
effectively does the same thing, except
I can't track that there's no difference
between
uh the
um
driver has raced in race triple
and all my other triples if I use an
insert query. So,
Uh what do you mean? Different like
different name graph?
Uh
Yeah, it could do.
Um it then you have to then know that
it's in a different graph.
Um
Yeah, I if you hand over that system it
may work slightly differently, but
um
Yeah, it doesn't Oh, and also
these
won't work with incremental or anything
incremental. So, if I then add new data,
you then have to go through the same
step. Um and again with retraction, so
if we're retracting um a driver or
something in this context doesn't really
make sense, but say that it does,
this would be a fixed data point, which
it wouldn't if we're we're doing
animals, so but yeah, fantastic
question. Yeah.
So, we also support SHACL
um for um like data validation, is that
what you're thinking? Yeah.
So, you can also do uh validation with
uh data log where you uh effectively
import um
like this is invalid. Um, provided uh
the the conditions of
something being invalid. So, you know,
um a a driver can't be a dog, so I'd put
>> Yeah.
>> uh a driver is a dog
import that it's invalid. Um,
so that worked perfectly fine.
Some people use Shackle if they want to
use Shackle.
Um,
you use data log if you're used to
writing data log. Um,
I don't know I haven't really used
Shackle that much to be honest, so I
don't know the syntax, but maybe you can
I I mean, certainly there's nothing you
can do in Shackle that you can't do in
data log. Um, but I wonder if
I wonder if there's you can be sort of
more expressive with your um
constraints. Cuz I mean, in Shackle can
you do like aggregates and negation and
stuff like that?
Yeah.
Then
I'm not sure. Is
>> where they go into a different named
graph?
>> Oh, do they? Oh, yeah, yeah, that's
right.
>> for the rules.
>> Yeah.
>> A graph for the data.
>> So, yeah.
That doesn't happen.
Um, you may or may not want that. But
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Um, again, it's
>> It's just It's It's a lot of choices
here.
>> There are a lot of choices, so
this we we say this a lot, like this
this is a tool. It's a very powerful
tool that we hand to you and now say
you you know, we'll help you, but like
this this is up to you to make these
choices. If if you want to choose to do
something insane, you can do something
insane. Um,
it will probably warn you not to, and we
will definitely warn you not to, um but
if you want to,
by all means, go for it.
Yeah.
>> I
want to know about
Um
So, uh you can write a construct query
that sort of creates these new
uh like properties effectively, but
they're
um they're like immaterial, so they're
not stored in the data. So, it would be
much slower. So, you anything you
compute, you have to compute at query
time. Whereas with this stuff, it's
pre-materialized, so anything you query
for
it's like it it is the same compute as
just a find and return query. Whereas
construct is going to be a lot slower
um unless you're doing something super
simple.
Is that kind of
getting an answer?
Yeah. Um and, you know, easier easier to
maintain incremental like all of these
it's it's basically the same
same benefits all the time. Uh it's
faster, easier to maintain, and you can
do incremental reasoning where you can,
you know, we're we're adding new data,
new rules, retracting stuff on the fly,
and it's maintaining itself up to date.
If I wanted to do that in a construct,
I'd just have to rewrite the query,
which you know
you can do, but you're just going to
have to do it again and again and again
and again and again. So.
Yeah.
Cool. Yeah.
Sorry, what's a QC workflow?
Mhm. Oh, yeah.
Yes, you can.
Um
that's a great question. Oh, man, I've
only got 10 minutes left. Um okay, I'm
going to breeze through this
uh
next little bit, but this is a really
cool part, so I want to show it off.
Um so,
let's make a search
for
uh these things and explore results.
So, we now have a bunch of drivers who
are
uh directly connected to a race. We can
explain these inferred
uh relationships in our explain tool.
So, here is the new relationship and off
screen,
this is why it is there.
So, you can see this relationship was
inferred because of this rule. This rule
was triggered because of this data.
And
there is an exact proof of why your data
looks like it does. And so, if you are
like, "Oh, well, that shouldn't be
there."
Go back.
Use this tool.
Find the rule that you've written that's
wrong. Find the data that you've
imported that's wrong. And then go from
there.
Sorry?
>> This works with fact rules?
>> Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. So, we've gone from um
an imported fact
um to its origin,
which again is pretty cool, particularly
in this world of like
LLMs and like black box stuff where like
nobody knows what's going on.
Um
Okay.
I say,
we're very short on time.
I really want to show you the coolest
stuff, so I'm going to skip through
loads of stuff and just just point out
what's cool. So,
in this rule, oh, these are also
exercises. If you want to do these in
your own time, please do. They're
they're not very difficult, so
um give them a go, but it will get you
used to like writing datalog. But here,
you can see that that we've used a
filter in a rule. So, we found a graph
pattern.
Uh in this case, we're finding the
result
and then ensuring or then finding the
position order. So, is it first or 10th
or last? And then saying that the
position order must be less than four.
And in this case, infer that this driver
has a podium in this race.
Quite cool.
In this one, we're doing an aggregate.
So, we're saying count the number of
races that this driver has raced in.
Again, we're using this new has raced in
relationship that we inferred with a
previous rule. So, they these are rules
depending on other rules.
Count the number of races that they've
been in. And now, we're going to infer
this new fact, driver has race count
race count. So, again, this count is now
a a fixed Sorry, not a fixed. It is a
fact in our database
that has been inferred by our rule. So,
um again, if they get a new race, it
will automatically be updated. The count
will increase incrementally without you
having to do anything.
Um
super easy.
Rule four is exactly the same. It's
about has race win count.
Same aggregate, except now we're
assuming or requiring that the position
order is one.
Uh oh, and again, we're using like binds
here so you can perform complex
calculations within the rules. So, you
can do things Uh in a second, we'll do a
win percentage. So, again, just one
thing divided by another. You can do
like In one of our demos, has something
that's uh akin to like time frequency
analysis.
Um you can get pretty pretty advanced
with it. So, all of this again is done
within rules. So that at query time, you
just query for the answer. So, again,
it's incredibly quick. Um almost sort of
real-time uh answers.
Anyway,
sorry for the the real rush.
Um
I I really prefer to like focus on the
questions cuz I think that's where um
the like main value comes in here. But,
this rule
I really want to focus on it and spend
uh a few minutes talking about because
it's super super important.
Um so,
we've seen
we've seen graph patterns, we've seen
aggregation, we've seen filters. These
are all things that go uh way beyond Owl
and let you encode stuff like finishing
first, second, or third, which is not
that complex of a concept, right? But,
it could not possibly have been done
with Owl, and now uh like business logic
is encoded in what is really quite a
simple rule.
This next thing
is about negation, which is the absence
of data. So, here we are
uh using our hasPodiumInRace um property
from the last uh
uh the last rule and saying,
"For any driver where this doesn't
exist,
infer that they are a driver that is a
driver without podiums. So, give them
the class driver without podiums."
And so, if they have not got this
property,
it will be inferred that they're a
driver without podiums.
Now this
is a bit of a problem
because we also offer incremental
updates. So, what happens if now, for
example,
a driver the next year
wins a race,
and we add this data in.
The reasoning engine has to keep track
of
these uh negatively inferred
uh fact and remove it because now data
has been added that invalidates the
previously inferred triple. So, we would
have to retract a fact based off the
addition of entirely separate
information without ever specifying that
we want to remove that fact just because
the rule already exists and this new
data also exists.
As it happens,
in 2021,
George Russell
achieved his first win having
raced in F1 for a couple of years. He
went from being a driver without podiums
to a driver with podiums. So, I'm going
to show you um
the sort of results of that now because
again it's it really is quite impressive
how
like easy this is.
Um so, I'm going to quickly run through
um and add my other rules.
How far did we get?
Rule five.
Okay. So, there's
there's all the rules in imported up to
the negation rule. So,
if we run
uh
George Russell
query,
which is just Russell,
we will see that up to the year 2020,
which is the data that we've imported so
far, he is a driver without podiums. So,
this query, this Russell query, just
queries for everything that we know
about George Russell.
We can see why because he's had loads of
races, but we don't have anything up
here about wins or podiums or anything
like that. Just that he has raced in
races and that he is a driver without
podiums.
Now,
if I go ahead and import
data
What's it called? 2021.
Oops. 2021.
23.ttl.
Just like that, 500,000 facts imported
again.
Now, if we rerun our
George Russell query,
we can see that he is not
a driver without podiums anymore. This
fact has disappeared. Well, it has not
disappeared, it has been retracted. And
if we scroll all the way to the top, we
can see he's got a lot more races, but
also he now has loads of podiums and a
win. So,
of course he's no longer a driver
without podiums, but that fact has now
been incrementally retracted, which
is
one of like the the hardest problems
that you can solve in like incremental
reasoning. So, this is why a lot of
people don't do it because that's really
difficult. Um
uh it is it is in fact a solved problem.
Um
So, rule six just shows you the
calculation. So, comparatively, that
that's boring.
Does anybody have any questions about
that? Because again, that was
unbelievably quick. Yeah.
>> I have a
question about another if you have a
example of another query.
>> Uh-huh.
>> So, if you have a sequence
of events
>> Mhm.
>> and you want to say, "Okay, if I have
this kind of sequence of events with a
lot of
rules
>> Mhm.
>> uh
that actually means transaction between
this and this.
>> Mhm.
>> You see what I mean?
>> Um I I think so. As in like um
>> look at what happens when you I think
it's in banking. I'm not from banking.
You transfer money from one account to
another. What actually happens doesn't
look like that, right?
>> Yeah.
>> a lot of events, but
uh
you can you want to create at the end
another edge, right?
>> Mhm.
Yeah, that's that's actually fine. And
that's one of the things that
I was sort of talking about um or I
alluded to
when I say you can go beyond queries,
right? Because that would be a very
difficult thing to do or or impossible
even to do with with a standard query.
So, what you can do is you can write a
recursive rule that is like
self-referential
but steps along your chain um
in fact, we have a demo that does
literally what you're describing
where it like steps along the chain
until completion and then says and makes
a new node and links all these things to
this new node and says, "This is my like
chain node. These are all the the parts
of the chain. This is its you know,
total value or time, whatever. It's like
a summary." And you've done that by
just you know, encoding one clever rule
that will
iterate over itself
until completion.
Um
It's quite advanced. I could show you
afterwards if if you're interested. Um
but yeah, it's a really cool feature
that um
I wish we had more time to talk about.
Um
Cool. Um
Let me show you one other
cool thing.
Not this one.
This one. This one. Here we go.
I'm going to run
uh what was it? Query.
That's not right. Sorry.
Query 13 and
query two, I think.
Um so, query two was our initial count
query uh where we did the has number of
race count you know, looking for that.
We can see that it took
0.05
seconds. If we run
query 13
0.001. So,
on on what is
really a simple query, you have got a
massive reduction
uh in time that it took to evaluate.
Right? And this is just because we are
performing in in this query, we're
performing a count at query time. With
this, because of the rule that we've
written, the the computation for the
count has been performed way ahead of
time and um we can just query directly
for the result. So,
yeah, what what was that?
Uh
what order of magnitude?
What, 50 times quicker? 56 times
quicker?
On
a 10-line query?
Like
that's crazy.
Um imagine this, but now with a real
production query that's 100 lines and
you have a sort of stack of rules all
building towards your goal. You can you
can achieve
uh something quite special.
Um
right.
There's a bonus exercise. Do it at home.
Um
right. We're out of time. I'm going to
rapid-fire these last five slides with
like 10 seconds a piece.
Audio Fox is an enterprise solution. It
has other things such as persistence, uh
access control, high availability,
external sources like CSV, SQL, that
sort of thing.
Um you can deploy it on device or on
personal machines or on large cloud
instance.
Um
uh this is something that we didn't
cover, but is really important, so I'll
I'll come back to it. Oh, so is that?
Okay.
If anybody wants to go,
I'm not going to stop you.
I'm going to I'm going to talk about two
things that are really important. One is
the types of reasoning um that you can
get. The other is how this fits into uh
rack. So,
one is sort of important for us. One is
important as like the topic of the day.
This one, the different types of
reasoning, you have pre-materialization,
which is what you've seen today, where
you upload a rule or import a rule,
everything is materialized, so you pay
the computation cost once, and then you
can query for the result with like,
you know, a a a query for a piece of
data. The other type is query rewriting,
which is like, um
uh we hate it because it gives reasoning
a really bad name because what it does
is it literally rewrites your query uh
as you execute the query to incorporate
these other things. So, if you take the
count example, it doesn't perform that
count up front.
You run the query, then it says, "Oh,
you were supposed to do this count, so
I'm going to do the count now." And then
every time you run that query, you
perform the count. And so, it doesn't
give you any performance benefits
whatsoever,
um and it's really rubbish. So,
don't use that. Uh only go for people
who are doing materialization.
But then, within that, often
materialization is just owl, so you miss
out on negation, you miss out on uh
filtering binds aggregation there's
no incremental, there's nothing like
that. Um so, you can't do
all this other cool stuff. So, again, if
you are looking at um
reasoners anywhere, just make sure
you're like asking these questions cuz
reasoning is a relatively new term, so a
lot of people say, "Oh, you've got
reasoning, great. You can do all of this
stuff." But you can't because
it because it's a broad term, but the
like industry hasn't really adopted the
specifics yet. It's still just this
broad church.
Um where does all of this fit into rack?
Well,
effectively, today you have sort of
three
pillars that you can choose from. One is
just using LLMs. Uh it's really good.
10 years ago, this would have been
magic.
Um
it's incredibly powerful. You can ask it
whatever you want. Anyone can use it. Uh
but it has the slight downside of lying
to you. Um which sucks.
So,
uh
kind of actually a lot of people in our
community
came up with RAG.
Which is where you ground these answers
in data. And you often use a vector
database for it. Um which is fantastic
because now you're getting
truth out of your um system.
However, RAG restricts the questions
that you can ask. So, you you lose some
of this flexibility
um and like power. You you still keep a
lot of it, which is why it's
you know, why it is so uh like such a
hot topic at the minute. Um but it is
much more limited.
So, if you want to do something like uh
talk to a chatbot and just say, "Find me
something that's approximately what I'm
after and then return it to me." Great.
Stop there. This this is all you need.
It's it'll be fast. It'll be everything
you want.
But, if you want to ask some of these
more complex questions again, you need
RAG and reasoning. And this is where
people have started to talk about
neurosymbolic AI. I've already heard
that like
quite a lot at the conference already.
So, I think that's probably going to be
the new sort of buzzword uh in like 6
months or a year or something. Um but
neurosymbolic
it enriches your data store with these
uh with this data that gives you things
like counts or like filters or like more
complex business logic that you can now
use RAG for and now get directly. So,
the the perfect question that we
uh or the perfect question to ask each
of these systems
um to sort of demonstrate
um
their their flaws and achievements is
how many things do I have?
This will make up a number. This will
not know. And this will just spit out
the answer straight away. And all you're
asking is count something. And like
you need that in business, right? Like
it it's
enterprise does not function without
things as simple as counts.
That's, you know,
forgetting all the other stuff that we
can do,
if it doesn't pass that threshold, it's
not good enough.
If you want to see a demo of that,
come to yes
or stick around. Uh I would show it, but
yeah, we're like way out of time.
Um
congratulations.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you for bearing with me.
Well done.